i'm living here
for eight months because i'm working in
kobe 19 center to save my family from
the virus
i try to make a distance from my family
this is my earth reason to live here in
living room
it's hard but you you live in one house
but
you feel us live another place
hannah sampson is a nurse at the saint
paul's hospital in ethiopia
like many low-income countries ethiopia
has struggled to secure vaccines
leaving its front-line workers in a
vulnerable position
in december 2020 hannah contracted the
virus while working at a covert 19
treatment center
they took me in the hospital
when i arrived at the millennium covert
care center
i lost my consciousness because i'm
afraid and everybody is
coming and caring of myself and they
took me in high dependency unit
i spent for the 16 days and they give me
oxygen
they give me unexplainable support for
me
they saved my life
for hannah and many other healthcare
workers in the world's poorest countries
getting a vaccine hasn't been an option
i was afraid when i was sick
and when i heard our colleagues
dying it's difficult time for me for my
family for my friends
colleagues but a global initiative
called kovacs
is trying to ensure that people in all
corners of the world get access to
vaccines
because of kovacs hannah was able to get
vaccinated
and it might be the best bet for
immunizing the rest of the world too
as rich countries race to inoculate
their populations
poor countries have fallen behind in the
biggest vaccination campaign in history
and that's a problem for everyone wildly
uneven and unfair that's how the un
describes the distribution of coveted
vaccines around the world
very few of those doses a very small
proportion of them have been used in low
and middle income countries
there's five or six of these variants
that i would say are of concern out
there the thing that we worry about the
most
that it will essentially evade the
protection
of the vaccine the pandemic has weighed
heavily on developing economies
take the example of ethiopia it's long
been seen as one of africa's most
promising economies
but the country has a sizable debt at
the end of 2019
its total public foreign debt stood at
27.8 billion dollars
according to the world bank the pandemic
has put pressure on the health care
system and the economy
leading ethiopia to ask for debt relief
under a g20 programme to help poor
countries
reeling under the economic impact of
coronavirus
many low-income countries even before
the pandemic were facing financial
constraints
huge debt loads and really didn't have
the financial capacity
to negotiate bilateral deals with the
vaccine developers
like developed countries europe and the
u.s were able to
i've long argued that pandemics are an
evolutionary certainty
seth berkley is the head of gabby the
vaccine alliance
he's an epidemiologist and you know he's
really devoted
you know the past year to fighting
the pandemic he conceived of this kovacs
initiative at davos
in january 2020 realizing that
when the pandemic really hit and we had
vaccines the real challenge would be
providing equitable access to countries
that couldn't afford to buy them on
their own
my job is to try to solve these problems
and put in place
systems to do that and so at this davos
meeting we heard about
this new epidemic that was going on it
was early days we didn't know if there
were people-to-people transmission but i
sat down with richard hatchett
who's the ceo of sepi the coalition for
epidemic preparedness innovations
and we discussed what we were doing so
that really was the beginning of the
collaboration of course
a lot happened since then at the end
they focused on the r d
we focused on the procurement and
delivery and who
focuses on the normative side of things
but
um we came together working like we do
in the alliance with multiple partners
for the first time we've seen the whole
world come together
at least in name in terms of kovacs and
wanting to move forward
more than 190 countries are
participating in the kovacs facility
the wealthy countries are participating
through paying for their doses
through this purchasing pool that kovacs
has set up while kovacs provides
the low-income countries with doses for
free through money it is raised
from governments development agencies as
well as
private sector contributions when we
decided to do kovacs
we didn't have any deals we didn't have
any money we had to go out and raise
money we had to begin to talk to
manufacturers and of course to make a
deal with a manufacturer
you have to have the finance in place
kovacs is a huge international effort
the biggest international effort since
the paris climate accords
it has required a massive fundraising
effort from governments around the world
it's a procurement challenge they've had
to negotiate
deals with pharmaceutical companies to
secure doses on timing and delivery
and then at the same time they've had to
prepare countries around the world
for the rollout on the ground and that
has
been a huge you know logistical
challenge the arrival of this particular
vaccine has come as a great relief to
health workers and a lot of ghanians
kovacs
is aiming to deliver 2 billion doses by
the end of the year
it has so far raised almost seven
billion
dollars it just came out with a new
initiative to raise an additional
two billion but there's still a long way
to go
they need more money and they need more
doses is it enough what they
have achieved of course it's not but
it's not a question of money for the
time being it's a question of
what access to vaccines
do they are they going to be given by
others
so that they can take care of the
majority of the world population
what is surprising is that wealthy
countries haven't donated more
to kovacs given that it's really in
their self-interest
if the virus continues to rage
in low-income countries that will only
mean that it's
likely to boomerang back into uh
the developed world new mutant strains
will develop
and it'll be incredibly hard to stop
covet in its tracks right now we have a
situation where wealthy countries have
worded many times
of the amount of doses they need
it's really time now to turn that around
and either begin to
make those doses available through dose
sharing
or to free up the places in the
manufacturing queue and that will
allow doses to go across the world get
us to a place where we can end the acute
phase of the pandemic as quickly as
possible
but it's not just the wealthiest
countries complicating kovacs's efforts
it's been pretty challenging for kovacs
to get its own supplies
vaccine nationalism is still front and
center vaccine nationalism is a huge
challenge for the kovacs initiative
it's heavily dependent on the
astrazeneca vaccine
because of its low cost and easy
distribution
astrazeneca is producing the vaccine on
its own
as well as through an independent
manufacturer in india called the serum
institute
but india itself is facing a second wave
of infections
and has curbed large-scale exports of
the vaccine
the other challenge that kovacs faces is
its
dependency on the astrazeneca vaccine
which
has seen these reports of rare blood
clots
associated with the shot and that has
given rise to vaccine hesitancy
around the world you've seen reports of
people not showing up and doses going to
waste
because of concerns about the safety of
the vaccine
even though those reports are
exceedingly rare
i think it does pose a challenge for
rolling out doses worldwide
there are also major challenges to
produce the vast quantity of vaccines
needed around the world
normally in the world we use about three
and a half billion doses of vaccine
a year if you add flu to that it ends up
being about 5 billion
people are talking about trying to cover
the whole world that would be another
10 to 15 billion doses
that would have to be done in the course
of this year that would be a quadrupling
of global supply
that is very ambitious not just for the
manufacturing capacity but also the
raw materials the supplies the staff and
so this is a real challenge for the
world
pharmaceutical companies have been
criticized for not releasing their
formulas
so that more manufacturers can produce
at scale
some say kovacs should be doing more to
pressure them
anna marriott the health policy advisor
for oxfam
argues that these manufacturing issues
could have been mitigated by kovacs
you know i think right from the outset
kovacs
should have used its enormous leverage
it could have pushed
those pharmaceutical corporations to
share the vaccine science and know-how
we know that there are many offers on
the table from manufacturers
from bangladesh pakistan to denmark and
canada
who are coming forward now and saying we
could help make these vaccines
if the vaccine science was was shared
and the intellectual property
rules removed if we'd done that much
earlier on those manufacturers could be
helping us now
making those vaccines it's certainly not
too late we do have to act now
but kovacs argues the issue lies in
teaching other manufacturers the
detailed analytics
tests and quality assurance procedures
needed to make the vaccines
the issue is not for vaccines that
patents are the blocker there may be a
patent or two but those
could be gotten around if one needed to
the real challenge is can you get those
thousands of pages of know-how
and can you have those transferred
beyond the immediate manufacturing
problems hampering kovacs's rollout
lies an even bigger problem the
initiative's donations will provide
doses that will cover only about 30
of populations in low-income countries
that's nowhere near what's needed to
achieve herd immunity
countries like ethiopia for instance is
entirely dependent on the kovacs
initiative
it has something like 110 million people
and so far it's only administered about
400 000 doses so they have a long way to
go
before they get anywhere near what you
know
scientists believe is hurt immunity to
stop the pandemic in its tracks
kovacs may not be a silver bullet to the
world's vaccine equity problem
but ending the pandemic will be almost
impossible without it
well kovac is the solution to it there
is no other one
which tell me which other organization
has
tried to bite the bullet here which
other organization has been so ambitious
that they are promising to do everything
what it takes
to give a vaccine also to those who
cannot afford it
there is no other one so they have to be
supported
of course at the end of the day the real
question now
is will the doses be available will the
companies make the doses
will as high income countries reach a
certain threshold begin to say we'll
release some of the excess doses
that we have and make those available
and we'll be we be able to scale up
manufacturing
if we can do that then we'll be in a
world where
the world has been protected during a
pandemic
if we can't do that we will be in a
world that is very
unfair and very inequitable and that's
exactly
what we're trying to stop through kovacs
[Music]
[Music]
you